адже сила q hurry to create 90
кілометрів ті роки на їзди автомобілем
на багата дав шлях до столиці по
інтернету та від знайти сільських чиновників
та депутатів
ній вікна може кудись я декларації
простий ставкою хочеш по винес роботи
cdp кроку крикни сільському голові
Володимиру по-великому вдалося а кудись
це клара тью першин за допомогою сина
програміста дпр вини ряд winter
якісних пенсіонерів не вбити
курського ти себе вони комп'ютером вони
інтернетом і відкривши цілей я б взяв їх
кулька тому не любить риба організовує
ви розумієте люди чи взагалі мій news
ну присвятили маленькі речі ну я розумію
якунін ось види зусилля поранив і намети
комп'ютери та сільському булавину було все
організувати і кілька дорожчих депутатів
в дурня центру за технічною допомогою
віку обіцяти відкинув і дурний доступ
з true олесунда нюансу мої доктора ти і
ви на кого труднощі приємні
процедури є просто реп впевнено
приходила і всі мої ранки щоб ветивер
є приходом 51 ранку на так я
була вся правильна, а правити не
можна скоротити arcotel раді який на
коваль по протрави чого святі то в
міні-курс twas the sea комп'ютером з 9
бар зрада чоловікові повиті дурою з true
надзвичайно що жива і на сон, і на
все на світі і не спала і
фоки вчора вже не здала перехрестилася і
хоч виспалася ці м'яч у кухар охолодж
s750 між council
сади у вигині вшивого незаміжні новосиби
але підвиди його дата нас на міс
цілих мініпіг агентствах протирати
максимум 120 людей за все ще тут
дмухається куму як таїться в оренду земля
ягоду згубна сила головний платних по
дотці блешні в я фінансуються всі вуста
нової і побачить лише ятри крижини
приховано раді бухгалтер та голова за
че і відривати зарплат не тим часом
із 12 депутатів
малюка одні jarrell обробку по
середньому 2000 гривень пенсії за свою
діяльність он і на відьому вигляд
депутати Верховної Ради зарплатна ранку
мій плюс практично наймає приводу важливий
для пливу на рішення символом нової
куртці нір мови та інших мінімальні на
речі тисячі таких сільських народних у
братів за раз на магніті з приводу лотару
естр декларації сільських головок йшов
на розумі я думаю ще потребуємо було
подумати для бджіл зарубати інші
просто просто він і спожив у нас за
сварки та сміттям ось дуже всю систему
я кобури this крупу котрий ковадло
найгірше обидва і колію постраждав це ж
схожі їжу в день передплатники до дня
з 12 депутатів не падав і січа троє його
треба допомагати їм відомо легше реєстр
запитав я їх slide